ladies and gentlemen it is my pleasure
to present this man he's a two-time Tony
winner three-time Oscar nominee and
winner of the Academy Award for his
performance in the fortune cookie
here is the sloppy one mr. Walter
Matthau
tonight we pay tribute to a man whose
life and work proved that success and
decency can coexist within the same
career and what a career it has been
from second assistant director on keys
of the kingdom through his directorial
debut with big house USA to the host of
films that bear his name Plaza suite The
Odd Couple on a clear day you can see
forever some kind of hero The Manchurian
Candidate none but the brave and
airplane
Howard Koch joined the Academy in 1951
and was elected to the Board of
Governors in 1969 he served in various
offices before his election of president
in 1977 he's a three-time chairman of
the permanent Charities Committee of the
entertainment industry in 1985 he
received the motion picture and
television fund silver medallion in
recognition of his contribution and
efforts on behalf of us all he chairs
the Directors Guild education and
benevolent foundation he's a trustee of
the motion picture and television
benevolent fund he has also produced a
record eight Academy Award shows be that
as it may Howard Koch will now sing oh
to be in England in the spring
the recipient of this year's Jean
Hersholt Humanitarian Award mr. Howard W
[ __ ]
I'm really not a bad guy thank you dear
Walter for this wonderful wonderful
introduction and thank all of you for
the earth what you've just done I think
I lost what I was going to say because
I've never had a moment like this and
I'm much better behind the camera it
seems strange to receive an award for
living your life what has ever seemed
special to others Maya that I may have
done there's only a part of my life a
life I have with my family at home not a
life I have with my family I work I love
what I do I really do is it's a great to
be in this industry my life has been its
own reward
well you to add is such a special honor
this evening well there simply are no
words
my paramount family and my family's
crying right there right now come on my
paramount family which I've been part of
the last 26 years where they called me
dr. Koch my own family my wife Ruth by
love and adore and without you I'd still
be saying to murder in Laroy I'm ready
when you are mr. Leroy but I love you
and my daughter my lovely daughter
Melinda well anyone we proud to have her
daughter in her Allen handsome guy
Howard jr. who hopefully will be
standing right in the stage one day
receiving his is Oscar now all my
grandchildren are here tonight now wait
a minute can't remember them well a
couple of them let's see there's Wendy
and her Tim Carol Robbie and Billy the
northwestern flash they are Billy my
sister Lola oh I forgot Emily I told you
come back rolling back and my
granddaughter Emily Emily the most
beautiful one of the family I'm sorry my
sister Lola that's the way my sister
Lola before I forget my secretary Laurie
we wrote every letter I dictated and
made it better that's true Laurie
wherever you are you know there's an old
saying that it's more blessed to give
and receive
but tonight if I may it's more blessed
to receive thank you Thank You Aubrey at
steady old penny